(gentle music)
- [Pardis] Early on when my
research wasn't going that well,
and I was having trouble,
people would be like,
well, she's in a band.
But then when my research
started going well,
and I started publishing,
they'd be like wow,
and she's in a band.
- [Bob] One, two, three, four
♪ Count me out ♪
♪ Don't count me out ♪
- [Pardis] People think that
you have to be one-dimensional
to be a scientist, but actually
your science gets better
when you stimulate your creativity,
your curiosity, all of that.
So to me actually, doing music
helps me be a better scientist.
♪ Count me out ♪
♪ Don't count me out ♪
I'm Pardis Sabeti, I'm a geneticist
and I'm a National
Geographic Emerging Explorer.
I use math to dissect
the genomes of viruses,
to decode them, and understand
how they evolve, how they spread
and ultimately how to
prevent infectious disease
and prevent outbreaks.
I was born in Tehran, Iran.
I came here when I was just a little girl.
And the middle school me
was just a little girl who loved math.
So much, I just loved the
logic and the puzzles,
and just as soon as I really
got into it, I never stopped.
Math is a powerful tool to
mine vast amounts of data,
genomics is just thousands,
millions, billions of letters
that you're trying to decode, decipher,
using math, using computers.
That's what I do and that's what I love.
So a virus is a microscopic
thing that can infect us
and can cause a lot of
harm, can make us very sick.
And I study all sorts of viruses,
from the common flu to Ebola.
Ebola is a very deadly virus.
It can have really high mortality rates,
and it can spread really quickly.
(soft music)
In kind of these worst case
outbreaks it can be 80%,
which is why we're
really worried about it.
An outbreak is an infectious disease
that's gotten out of control.
You can think of it like a wildfire.
You never really know
where one will start,
but you need to detect it
and you need to contain it
before it gets out of control.
That's what my work does
for infectious disease, for outbreaks.
During the 2014 outbreak
of Ebola in West Africa,
we essentially, when a patient's infected,
their blood sample is taken for diagnosis.
We're able to take that sample,
deactivate the virus within it
and ship it to the United States
where we were able to prepare them
and put them on sequencing machines
and read out their genomes.
(soft music)
So once we sequence a virus' genome,
it might look something like this.
This is actually Ebola's genome sequence
and there's clues in here.
And we can use math and computation
to start to decipher those clues.
Learn about the virus'
history, and how it's changing.
All of this is arming us
towards better detection,
surveillance, prevention.
Really to be able to
put out that wildfire.
(upbeat music)
As somebody who studies
infectious diseases,
we're most successful when
nothing happens, right?
We are trying to stop
outbreaks from ever occurring.
And so we're most
successful at that point,
when we put out the sparks
and you never hear about it.
But that's sort of an exciting challenge.
So one of the tools we created
is an outbreak simulation
that's spread over Bluetooth
from phone to phone
for middle schoolers, to get to experience
what an outbreak might be like,
but before a real life event.
So you know we created this
tool to be able to educate
and have outreach to students,
but really we learned as much
from them as anything else.
Their participation taught us
about how people respond to outbreaks.
Their ingenuity, their thought process
during the outbreak taught us so much.
I love working in outbreaks
because it requires cooperation,
it requires people working
together, collaborating
and that's how you win.
It's sort of the way I like
to think about the world.
I mean I'm in a band, I'm
not a singer, songwriter,
I like being part of a collective.
It's where the best things come together.
(guitar strumming)
♪ When I breathe out ♪
♪ I breathe out love ♪
- [Pardis] All right, there we go.